are you going to do foreign a
compilation or something that kind of
interesting i was trying to say that i'm
going to do the compilation probably
before the album so that's going to come
first indy
drop it independently yeah that's so
wing going i ain't trying to even
that's smart good show like i'm gonna
tell you though like some real [ __ ]
like boom shout out like i said y'all be
test get rich zay cocaine mali boss flip
banner prince glock boy keys all these
artists that i'm naming
they do views that
artists is signing like ain't doing and
these are artists that are going to be
on your label yeah these these young
[ __ ] ain't
they just damn rapping right right right
and the label is called stun stunner
world what is it no it's welcome to foe
vegas welcome to phoebe and that was my
last mixtape but i wanted that to be an
album too i wanted to do that bigger
than i did it right but
feel me
well everything is a lesson you feel me
so like i say we're gonna that's gonna
be the album
name too for the compilation
it might be like a throw off on it or
something but yeah that's going to be
the weapon of vegas records for sure